this is this is crazy cops recover
suicide note after deranged man drove
car packed with explosives into crowd at
Rochester concert killing two so
apparently what happened was this guy
loaded his SUV with explosives I believe
it was gasoline or something and he was
trying to ram a crowd of people as an
Uber pulled out he then T-boned the Uber
killing the people inside and uh uh
injuring several others around it but I
believe that Uber may have inadvertently
saved many lives it's a wild story this
happened uh I believe it happened on the
and they believe it may be a terror
attack it's being investigated as an act
of terrorism we will see but what a way
to kick off
2024 so as we're seeing stories like
this you know I get to thinking uh about
the conversations I had with family
extended family members over the uh
holiday and they ask questions about
like do you really like you talk about
Civil War but like like what what's the
likelihood you really think and I'm just
like time travel test man if you went
look right now the corporate press says
that a bunch of men conspired to kidnap
Gretchen Whitmer now obviously we
contest a lot of those allegations the
corporate press says that January 6 an
Insurrection was attempted to all these
leftists who are calling me crazy for
saying I fear Civil War they're the same
people claiming that Donald Trump
literally tried to start a civil war
it's the weirdest thing like Donald
Trump tried to overthrow the government
in a in in a coup with his supporters
who stormed and attacked the capital
Civil War will never happen like uh
then you're not scared of trump and his
supporters in MAA in
2024 Aris rinos I'm probably pronouncing
his name wrong I worked with him briefly
uh when I was at Vice news he's a good
dude he says he writes for unheard the
world should fear 2024 escalation lurks
on every Battlefield now of course he
talks mainly about foreign policy but he
does mention in the article that
escalation will exists in American
domestic uh discourse as well so I
think man you know we got a Super Chat
already saying beware the Ides of March
I'm like come on bro that's like three
it's like 2 and a half months from now
literally it's 2 and a half months from
now wow when we had Eric princeon just
before the end of the year I asked him
is there something like what does he
what does he see here in the United
States does he see anything happening
you know akin to this with with with
what he's seen in other countries and he
he said the one thing that every guy
who's been in a civil war Revolution
period and conflict and crisis can tell
you is that it happens over
one day everything's normal you wake up
there's no electricity there's no radio
there's no internet that's what people
don't
realize you may go outside and go to the
mall and you're like everything feels
normal and this is the normal cbias that
people on Twitter talk about on on X
they'll say oh you guys talk about all
this stuff go touch grass because when
you go to the mall when you go to the
movies no one cares about any of this
stuff and I'm like right in Egypt during
the revolution nobody cared about this
stuff so let me let me tell you I went
to a place called utag do you guys know
what that is no do you know what Barrow
Alaska is yes yeah they changed the name
in
2016 uh the native I believe it's the
inak people referred to the area as UT
gagik UT is it UT kagic yeah it's UT
kagic and uh when Western settlers came
they referred to it as Barrow uh Point
Barrow whatever and then those settlers
buil built up a training post in a city
that they called
Barrow in uh 2016 a group of activists
this is this is what I was told by uh
some of the locals that I had met they
said that like 86 people voted at it's
it's a town of four 4,500 people it's
like 86 people voted and it was like by
one or two votes to change the name to
utvic and so I was like the school says
Barrow on it the airport calls it Barrow
the the uh Airlines call it Barrow the
airport is called Barrow brw but they
changed the name and he's like it was
like 40 something people and I'm like
40s something people voted and changed
the name of your city and he goes it's
still Barrow I heard that from several
people and I tweeted about it I was like
wow dude some decolonized activists were
like this place is called utak not
Barrow so we're going to hold a vote
nobody shows up nobody cared and so 40
people I tweeted this out and it's
really funny cuz I got a mix of people
uh who are like you're racists for not
supporting indigenous people's rights
even though I did not criticize the name
change at all the point I made was
twofold do not let a small group of
psychopaths dis change your community
without your consent and more
importantly that famous saying never uh
let it never be said that a small group
of dedicated people can't change the
world indeed it's the only thing that
ever did 40 some odd people decided to
change the name of that cting they did
it that was my point and then I get
people being like you just hate Natives
and Native Americans and I was like I'm
from Illinois dude I don't care that
they call it utag that's fine I know I
my have friends from alanin like the
names of all of our places are native I
don't care are are like the the you know
Eskimos or the Inuit people are are they
really all that angry at the white man
it's not like the white man took their
land nobody wants that property there I
don't believe so I believe actually a
good portion of the people again I'm not
from so I don't know but I the the way
it was explained to me is this is
probably like it's like white liberals
woke people I was told woke people yeah
so yes it probably does include some of
the indigenous but the the natives
didn't really talk about it all that
much I don't know didn't didn't seem
like it wasn't an issue mostly when I
met one native guy he was really excited
to explain how they kill whales and it
was it was wild how he told us how they
do it been talking to the same 10 people
for the past 30 years he oh yeah and
then he sees us and he's like here's
what we do like get him the same stories
to these new people and they're Rea this
going to be awesome dude the the the
native dude who explained wailing did
not come up to us and be like the white
man did this and did that he was like
let me tell you how we kill whales and
I'm like it's illegal for us to kill
Wales he's like yeah but not us I
thought that was kind of crazy too but
it was it was wild to see as we're
coming into
2024 I'll I'll remind people
of I'm in Egypt during the revolution
and I went to heliopoulos went to the
mall people were buying burgers and just
living their life and I got a kebab it
was delicious and I went to a store and
I bought a cell phone it was like
nothing was happening meanwhile there
was a revolution in taher square
Blackhawks flying overhead apcs through
the streets people were shooting and
killing each other but out a block away
at the McDonald's seriously it's like
two blocks McDonald's two blocks away I
think it's McDonald's uh from terer
there's a guy just eating a burger and
fries and watching soccer if more people
had had a firsthand experience with that
or or knew someone that did and
understood that there would be far fewer
people saying that a civil war will
never happen in the United States
because a civil war absolutely could
happen in the United States doesn't mean
that everybody's going to be involved
doesn't mean that people aren't still
going to go to it's never everybody it's
always some tiny tiny faction and and
the issue is you take a look at what
happened with the culture War and the
shift most regular people did not like
wokeness but were too afraid to say
anything think about how many people
didn't want to go along with the
mandates but did because they were
scared that they couldn't do it there's
one video where a guy a woman's filming
and a guy's stalking her in a super
supermarket saying she's not wearing a
mask if we have to wear masks she has to
wear masks you see what they were really
mad about the oppression and they want
you know misery loves company so anyway
my point is this as we're seeing this
stuff entering
2024 dude if if the people who are on
Twitter like go touch grass these people
have no idea what conflict is actually
like go watch the videos from the
destruction of of Aleppo and what will
you see you'll see people walking with
bags of groceries through Rubble filled
battlefields with gunfire someone's
going grocery shopping you talk to that
person what they're worried about and
they're like oh I got to get milk for my
family yeah that's touching grass I
think the pain points are starting to
increase though because the guy that
just wants to go get milk for his family
what happened to the price of that milk
what happened to the price of the pump
and I think hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of migrants we keep seeing the
videos I just was in the Phoenix Airport
you could see the illegal immigrants all
over the the floor over there just like
Ashley stclair and Taylor Hansen took
video of uh in Europe when you had that
number of migrants and now they're
coming from Africa they're coming from
the Middle East it's not just it's like
they've emptied out Central America
already into America uh when you have
that level of migrants they're doing
inordinate amounts of crime crazy
amounts of crime and the pain points of
everyday Americans we keep having these
this many people come through the
southern border that pain point is going
to increase to the normies paying
attention I think that normies are
actually starting to get tuned into a a
crazy uh level than they used to be that
video of that marjerie Taylor green
posted where you can see the thousands
running under the barrier and running in
when I showed that to normies they
flipped out yeah and I'm I'm not
exaggerating they were just like what
what is that what's going on and I'm
like that's our border right now and
they're like we don't have a country
anymore if that's the case most people
are like Maryann Williamson remember I
mean she was appalled that most of the
things that we showed her she had no
idea completely and totally ignorant and
this woman is running for president and
ostensibly has access to as much
information as she could possibly want
but like we were talking about earlier
people are afraid to go to to to uh
platforms like this or come to places
like this and because of that they are
fed a narrative that is not based in
reality that is not based in facts on
the ground and they they look at actual
real things when they hear about them
and they they're shocked just the other
night I was hanging out with uh some
other parents that we know and they're
fairly apolitical but they understand
more or less you know what kind of
what's going on but not to any degree
that we talk about sure and I felt I
started to feel bad because I was
telling them about my reporting from
Yuma and I felt like I was breaking
their hearts and their spirit cuz they
were so appalled and I'm like and I I
kept going cuz I'm like I'm not even
done I have so much more to tell you
that it is so crazy dystopian down there
and I could see it in their eyes being
like this is insane um it's so alarming
and then back to the the Civil War stuff
I always think about the day before
lockdown in New York in the suburbs
where I was I I it dawned on me to go
report from a gun store and see what was
going on CU there was like this fear
being pumped in I was thinking about
there's this band Phil you know what I'm
talking about every time I die they have
a lyric called paranoia is the disease
of the unarmed I think that's from last
night in town and I thought of that
sentence that lyric and I was like I'm
going to go to the gun store going it's
a great line I went to the gun shop it
was Mayhem there were people running in
who never owned a gun buying rifles and
shotguns I saw two people in such panic
mode leave their guns there after they
buy they bought them I saw another guy
outside leave his gun on the car and
drive off without it they were fre it
was there was nothing on the walls
anymore the ammo was gone I got a lot of
ammo for my shotgun but like it was
crazy watching people and so like at
that point Society hadn't collapsed the
way it has now and they were just afraid
of other people and they got to protect
themselves and in uh my my favorite
thing about it was in in California
there was a guy who owned a gun store
posted a video and he was like stop
yelling at me that you can't buy a gun
it's not my fault you voted for weight
periods you voted for these restrictions
and now you have to abide by them here's
the reality though it was funny to watch
but these liberals didn't vote for
anything yeah this is the issue with
wokeness UT gagik exemplifies it when
the vote was announced that they were
going to change the name 4,500 people
said I don't care and you know what to
be fair I honestly don't care the name
is UT gagik versus Barrow like I said
I'm from Illinois you know they they
they initially wanted to name West
Virginia conoa these are Native American
terms in Illinois you've got like I
mentioned El ganin a lot of these places
are named by the Native Americans
because the colonists who came in didn't
just make up new names for it what's it
called Illinois okay great we'll call it
Illinois right and and then and then
there's uh many things that they did
name that's totally fine on this issue
though my point
is a small amount of people who do care
will take from you everything you hold
dear if you don't pay attention thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net